poo
everybody does it i don't but with the
exception of new parents and
six-year-olds most of us don't talk
about it
but could our number twos be the answer
to some of the world's biggest
[Music]
problems the average adult flushes away
730 liters of pea and around 91
kilograms of feces every year
but are we missing a trick
in ancient rome no human waste went to
waste untreated excrement was used as
manure in kitchen gardens while urine
was used to produce fabric in henry the
eighth time one of the country's top
positions was groom of the stool
wiping the king's bottom was well worth
it for the benefit of having his ear
above that castle
cesspits were emptied overnight by gong
farmers who sold the content to local
farmers urine was collected and used to
soften leather while it's probably
sensible to leave untreated manure in
the past where it belongs think of the
pathogens
we can learn from our predecessor's
attitude to poo
it could be the solution to some of our
most pressing problems of today
let's start with our need for energy
unlike solar or wind power which can be
unreliable all it takes is a healthy
fibre intake to ensure a constant supply
of poo now that's a whole other kind of
wind power
the sludge left behind after sewage is
processed is good raw material for
generating methane
modern treatment plants add bacteria to
the sludge generating biogas which can
be piped to homes or used to power
vehicles it's a much cleaner fuel than
petrol or diesel
while poo has plenty of uses there's a
reason we is number one
72 of global water use is in agriculture
and population increases coupled with
climate change will only exacerbate the
demand for water
some countries could face having
populations displaced by water scarcity
within the decade
in addition to the two litres of pea
each adult in the uk produces daily each
adult also sends around 140 litres of
water used at home down the drain could
recycling that water save the planet
from apocalyptic droughts
absolutely the technology is available
and already in use
israel currently captures almost 90
percent of used water which is recycled
to provide a whopping 56 000 olympic
swimming pools worth of water annually
for agricultural use
speaking of agriculture every living
thing relies on phosphorus to survive
but due to chronic over-mining it's a
rapidly declining natural resource which
can't be replenished
the u.s china and india might run out of
their domestic supplies in the next
generation
without adding this vital nutrient to
farmland humanity could only produce
around half the food it does today
we could however emulate our ancestors
and return our sewage to the soil
making use of solutions such as
composting toilets or the nutrient-rich
dried residue left over from biogas
generation
reinventing the toilet could also be a
game changer for 4.2 billion people
currently living without access to safe
sanitation
innovative toilet designs that operate
without water could help prevent the
deaths of an estimated 800 children
under 5 each day bill gates predicts
this developing toilet market will not
only be life-saving but lucrative
by 2030 toilets could become a 6 billion
us dollar market with every dollar spent
providing a five dollar return
while poo remains a word that never
fails to raise a giggle your fecal
matter is no laughing matter
if we act now who may very well help to
save the planet
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video